to owens's Super Bowl 39 performance
might actually be one of the greatest
we've ever seen But if you remember
correctly it almost didn't happen see
during 2004 to was having another Pro
Bowl caliber season but things took a
drastic turn he broke his leg in a week
14 match up against the Cowboys and the
doctors mentioned that even if the
Eagles made it to the Super Bowl the
possibility of him playing in that game
would be a stretch hours before the game
no one knew that too was going to sued
up except him and what he did following
his surprising appearance was nothing
less than spectacular on one leg too
racked up nine catches for 122 yards
showing that on the field he was as
tough as they come and while his efforts
weren't enough to knock off the pat too
had one of the most unforgettable
performances in Super Bowl history